you know i have a cat that's 20 years  old and then we got a couple dogs a  couple years ago we have to put up a  gate right so our house is divided in  half the cat has one half of the house  and then all of you live on the other  side yeah  you've awarded the cat half of your home  his house is so big he can he gives half  of it to a cat and the other half to a  dog yeah the cats and dogs just they  can't you know dogs cats getting along  just fine but dogs were there first yeah  cat came in but when the cat came in was  introduced in our house the cat kicked  the dog's ass same like like i mean oh  yeah yeah then established dominance  absolutely and now it's it's stasis yes  our cat my cat was like i'm from the  streets you know like yeah and the dogs  were like i'm from somewhere fancy i  don't know  i don't know where i'm from